8 want to help that's why today we are
launching an urgent appeal the dec
turkey Syria earthquake appeal
tonight after the Evening News appeals
will be broadcast on BBC ITV Channel 4
channel 5 sky and across radio
they will be presented by Daniel Craig
tamzin Greg and Sir Michael Palin
we are hugely grateful to all for
getting this message out
by working together
with our Charities on the ground and
their local Partners we hope to reach
millions of people across the region who
are in need of immediate help to survive
the earth earthquake
has destroyed thousands of buildings in
turkey and in Syria leaving people in
freezing conditions
we've just heard that now more than 17
000 people have lost their lives
and that number will only rise
many more are still trapped under the
rubble
millions are in desperate need of
humanitarian assistance
DEC Charities including Islamic relief
age International action Aid and the
British Red Cross are already in the
ground in turkey and in Northern Syria
providing life-saving Aid
but they need more funds to help rescue
people from the rubble and provide
further food clean drinking water and
shelter to the survivors
I've just got back from Ukraine where I
saw for myself the huge impact for the
donations from the British public are
having on people's lives now sadly
people in turkey and Syria need our help
I know DEC Charities can make a huge
difference there as well
today we have four Aid workers joining
us to tell us about the situation on the
ground
to provide an insight into how they are
reaching out to the most vulnerable
people with vital Aid
after they have spoken there will be an
opportunity for you to ask questions to
them so please do use the Q a function
at the bottom of your Zoom screen
first I'm going to introduce to you
Salah from Islamic relief
Salah is based in gesantep which has
been badly affected by the earthquake
hello please tell us what you have been
witnessing thank you Salah and and
welcome to to everybody thank you for
giving us the opportunity
um I arrived around 14 hours after the
earthquake
um the early hours of well late night on
Monday to gaziantep
um I've I've been working in in the
humanitarian space for more than 15
years I've been to many disaster zones
I've been to many War zones and I have
to say that the size and the scale of
this is unprecedented the numbers are
huge
um yesterday I spent
um a good 12 hours in Nordike
is in the is is a town of around 50 000
people in the province of gazian tep
um and specifically there the
municipality were reporting to us that
70 of the buildings have been completely
destroyed looking around there was such
and rescue operations going on
in everywhere everywhere you look there
was a search and rescue going on
um and and it was it was it was really
it was really difficult and and you know
there were glimpses at times of Hope
when people would find uh somebody had
been buried for you know 45 50 hours at
that stage it's that first critical you
know 72 hours in which we believe all
the key time in which we we want to take
people out of the rubble and they still
have that chance of survival that's been
badly impacted by the weather there are
Sub-Zero conditions where it's minus six
it's very very cold
um the buildings uh completely collapsed
it's shocking to see it it's widespread
organizations like Islamic relief um
we're focused on assisting the Civil
Protection Agency who are working really
really hard in the search and rescue
operations they're going on throughout
the night obviously shortage of
electricity shortage of
telecommunication shortage of Water
Supplies
um initially on the first day Monday
evening Tuesday lots of of the roads and
access to certain areas was a real
struggle there is still a struggle in
some places like hatai in one of the
other provinces uh here in in turkey
that has improved I must say the access
on the roads have improved so we're able
to have movement of vehicles and and
sort of Aid in in the areas that it
needs to get to has become a lot better
um the assistance of food and absolute
essential people are cold very very cold
people who had buildings or were living
in shelters that have not been destroyed
psychologically and emotionally they're
not and understandably they're not
willing to return to those and and
secondly the authorities are encouraging
people not to a few hours ago in the
morning we still felt a Tremor
um and that Tremor and added to that
lots of the buildings that you know
yesterday in nordicate where I was
yesterday was was 45 hours post
earthquake one of the buildings that I
was standing in front of part of it just
collapsed the because structurally the
damage that's been done slowly slowly
you know things will buildings will
still collapse on their own when there
is a Tremor or just by the sheer impact
of of the earthquake so people are
unwilling to return to shelters with
there's a mosque behind me and I wanted
to highlight this Moss because this was
a mosque initially used as a shelter but
it's been by one of the Tremors it
originally been impacted people were
were housed here and people have left
people have left it because it became
completely unsafe so initially we were
using sports centers mosques schools
sort of big facilities that are at
ground level that hadn't visually been
impacted as much by the by the Quake but
what actually is happening people are
refusing even if we're offering them
um a place they're refusing because of
the psychological impact of what's
happened and therefore they're we're
offering tents like other agencies are
doing we're finding a lot of families
that are choosing actually to remain on
the streets they find that as a safe
space you're finding a lot of people
burning fires a lot of people sleeping
in their cars it's it's difficult it's a
real challenge shelter food
materials to help people with the warmth
you know we did a distribution yesterday
for blankets I've never seen blankets be
distributed as quickly as we did them
yesterday it was unbelievable it would
you know it just the need and and how
cold people were
um now what we're seeing is is an
increase in need in a lot of the the
toilet and sort of uh latrines and and
sanitation facilities because of the the
sheer numbers that are outside of their
homes
um and what this is leading to we're
also now looking at some of the sort of
medical challenges
um and and and and the needs accordingly
because of the fact that a lot of the
hospital supplies need replenishing
um that's going to be replenished now
over the next couple of days but people
are are starting to feel now the
adrenaline of trying to find family
members uh what we're hearing now in
some of the areas this morning I was in
caraman uh manash and some they're
starting to call off some of the search
and rescue now we still have hope still
people were being recovered this morning
but when that's happening now people are
starting to accept the loss of family
members that may still be buried which
is which is really sad but what now
they're starting to focus and understand
that the injury that they had because
the adrenaline has sort of worn off now
and as they start to accept the reality
of what's going on which is is very hard
to accept they're realizing that the
medical you know the injury that is
worse there may be infections because of
some of the damage because initially
when it happened people are not
concerned about themselves they're just
concerned about family members but we're
getting a lot of people now with with
infections
um unfortunately a lot of illnesses that
are spread as people are sort of
grouping up together or whatever else
the the cleanliness and the facilities
or as you can imagine very stretched so
the appeal I guess is clear we need as
much support as possible
um we're here uh we've been here since
the the the the onset of the the crisis
in Syria so our operations are quite
comprehensive and it's put us in a
unique position as you mentioned in your
introduction where we've been able to
with the winterization that's going on
at the moment because of the Subzero
conditions that we're working with we
already had existing sort of supplies
that were in place so we've been able to
upscale we need to upscale all Aid
agencies now we're looking to upscale
because that would be the priority at
such a stage
um and to continue the work that's going
on
thank you Salah and uh we will come back
to you with some questions hopefully uh
towards the end
thank you I'd now like to introduce Dr
wassal jerk from northern Syria Dr jerk
works for the Syrian expatriate Medical
Association or SEMA a local partner of
DEC member charity age International
Dr Alger can you tell us more about the
situation in Syria
how is your organization responding and
what will be needed in the weeks and
months to come
hi colleagues and thanks for giving this
opportunity to pray for the situation in
over Syria as an earthquake uh
[Music]
well done three days ago the situation
is miserable in enough not for Syria as
uh my colleague in central relief
explained about the situation in Turkey
it's uh nearly comparable to the
situation in turkey with a big
difference about the capabilities
available in inside Syria comparing with
what the Turkish government
has actually has a government
in case of absence of any government
inside Syria or any associations
responding to the situation uh except
the civil defense with the defense with
the minor capabilities and Machinery
responding to the the civilians under
the the rubble and the the collapse the
buildings as civil defense announced
there are more than uh 1070 700 story of
deaths and more than 400 building
collapsed in Northwest Syria especially
Engineers rural if a friend paper and
was turned into idlib in in salkin
sarmada and and
the the parade and his cluster turkey
Hub announced more than two thousand
death and more than uh uh 12
000 injured people and the rescue
efforts is still continuing till now
with only the efforts of the civil
defense in extracting the people under
the rubble and the collapsed buildings
SEMA and the and other local ngos are
responding to this emergent situation uh
by providing or Pro and provision of the
Essential Health Services regarding
secondary health care in in the in about
19 hospitals and also with coordination
with health cluster and who audio and
agencies
who are providing these uh vital
hospitals in this response with a few
consumables and other needs SEMA is
operating three of these surgical
hospital actually all of them are
located in adlab at near to to Afrin and
genderis with capacity of about 200 bits
actually with black and shortage of fuel
medical consumables and medication and
also a shortage of Staff as
many of the staff are affected as a
normal people by the earthquake and lost
their families and sometimes lost their
lives and most of them are escaping now
to uh secure the shelter for their
families actually Seema lost two of
their field staff in the hospitals one
of them are female
which is working as a social mobilizer
for vaccination program and the surgical
assistant lost his left arm and the
whole family and his house
was collapsed by the earthquake and lost
his family and he is now sleeping in the
ICU unit in the in the same Hospital
who was working in Sima and other ngos
now responding uh in the affected areas
especially in Engineers by providing a
temporary shelter and SEMA now is
preparing for a small Center
for rescuing and receiving uh the the
idbs from the near answer surrounding
areas providing them with some drinking
water with bread with essential
essential food basket with ready to eat
basket the essential need now who can be
briefed by by the Essential Medical
consumables and medication fuel for the
hospital as the electricity is off for
the first three days of the earthquake
which is which was affected by the
earthquake
as the rest of the infrastructure of the
of the area and the other need maybe the
shelter the the drinking water the
citation and latrines
and
some clothes and blankets uh to to face
the the cold weather as my colleague
mentioned it is a Sub-Zero temperature
in the area
thank you Dr wassal and our sympathies
to the families and colleagues of those
who have lost their lives and our best
wishes to your colleagues who are still
receiving treatment we will come back to
you with some questions later on and a
reminder to those uh listening in please
do uh pop your questions into the Q a
and we will come back to them towards
the end of this press conference
I'd now like to introduce Russia
nostradin director of the Arab region
for Action Aid who have a particular
focus on women and girls Russia can you
tell us a little bit about what action
Aid and your local partners are doing
and and and especially to the women and
girls who have been affected by this
disaster
yeah thank you
elephant and girls as colleague as Dr
Russell said in Northwest Syria this uh
this earthquake hit the hit this area
which was already uh effect affected by
uh by Conflict for the past uh for the
past couple of years and the people
there have been through multiple
displacements Health Facilities Aid
workers there are strained by from years
of conflict and attacks and a lot of
people has gone as I said lost their
livelihoods not once or twice but but
more and women and girls in that area
were already living in a very very
vulnerable conditions also just before
before the uh the earthquake hit there
was a cholera outbreak in in the area
and uh and there are already harsh
weather conditions so so it came just in
a moment where where there was a lot of
need so it exacerbated the suffering of
of the people that's why support needs
to be like redoubled for for uh for
these communities as I said women and
girls are are usually face increased
risk on this of discrimination of abuse
and and violence during during these
times of Crisis what we have seen
through our and what was reported
through our partner is that a lot of
families and majority uh like uh who are
like uh
um of women and the children have been
spend their nights on the streets there
is for example lack of of tense so our
partners have been trying to set up
temporary shelters uh and through uh
through the work that we are doing with
them we're trying to equip these
shelters with the with food with
blankets with floor mats so that can it
can provide especially women and girls
with some sort of of privacy uh as Dr
Russell also said like health health
facilities were also uh affected and
they were already affected by um by the
by the conflict so for example today we
have like like limited maternity
facilities pregnant women uh uh are are
facing risk of complications with their
and the menstruating girls have little
privacy don't have access to the right
products to manage their uh their uh
their periods uh a lot of the say women
and girls safe spaces have been uh
destructed so this also means that women
lack some access to this uh to this uh
to these services and this is uh really
alarming
um in terms of like our our response and
what we immediately have done or
prioritized is to help our partners with
the search and rescue because as
colleagues had mentioned that this this
was this is a gap and especially in
Syria there is a lack of equipment so
we're trying to provide the needed
resources so for partners for local
Partners to perhaps rent these equipment
from inside from inside Syria to be able
to remove people from under durable
additional additional uh things to this
response include as I said food and
non-food items shelter uh hygiene kits
fuel there is a lack of electricity
there's a lack of electricity and health
facilities and the temporary shelters
that also affects the well-being of
women and girls that affect their uh uh
and increases their uh their their
exposure
um in addition in addition to that uh we
should not forget like the cycle
the psychosocial support that is very
much needed so we just started yesterday
mobile psychosocial support services for
for children including young girls and
we will be also setting up a a
alternative woman a safe spaces that
were already lost due to destruction so
women can have access to this and some
also a gbv uh related Services because
this is very much needed in uh in the
areas
um this is basically the the general the
general picture as I said the uh the
area there is in a huge need and has
been going through a lot so that's why
it needs more more focus it we need to
redouble the the support for for this
area to be especially the northwest of
Syria uh Dr wassail mentioned the uh uh
like Sarma Dalek Sulkin there is and
there is is another area that is very
much affected all of these areas I mean
we are trying first to to move to the
most affected areas but also not to miss
that there are other areas of course
less affected but they also need need a
lot uh so yeah that's it from uh from
our end thank you
thank you thank you our final panelist
is Jeremy Smith head of region for the
British Red Cross Jeremy through the Red
Cross and the red crescent family you
are working in both turkey and Northern
Syria can you tell us a little bit about
your rapid response please
but thanks Ella yeah that's correct and
within 10 minutes of the earthquake
happening in Aleppo and Northern Syria
we had Syrian red presidents ambulances
responding heading to the sides uh
search and rescue was the priority for
the first 72 hours of this response and
Syrian red president Turkish present
volunteers and staff were supporting in
the search and rescue effort trying to
find people under Rubble getting them to
emergency medical equipment as sent as
quickly as possible we also uh mobilize
the International Road response so the
Lebanese Red Cross Center surgeon Rescue
Team on Monday to Tokyo and in the early
hours of Tuesday morning into Syria to
help with discussion rescue to relieve
people who've been working more than 24
hours straight digging through the
rubble
um but adjacent to that you know we want
to ensure that we're responding to the
needs of the survivors and keeping them
alive and keeping them safe and keeping
them healthy you know the other
panelists have talked about this as well
but ensuring blank gets intense the
Turkish red crescent have been
supporting this with more than two
thousand tenths they're supported with
half a million meals they have 77 food
trucks at the moment trying to get odd
meals to people in Syria blankets tents
mattresses have been distributed in if
Hama in Aleppo by Syrian president
volunteers and that will will continue
um we know that you know as others have
said people don't want to return home
that they're scared it's understandable
but we want to ensure that people have
as much as possible a safe place to
sleep at the moment as Russia said you
know this isn't really a crisis within a
crisis is in in Syria we've just had a
cholera outbreak we had a winter storm
the week before this happened
temperatures of below freezing so we
want to make sure that we can get
immediate response there as much as
possible in Syria and in Turkey I mean
our teams are at the moment are also
doing psychosocial first aid we have 10
teams in Turkey supporting people uh
with psychological first aid supporting
building the framework for for longer
term mental health support but also
doing Assessments in Syria and in Sofia
doing the kind of household assessment
trying to get an accurate picture with
other eight organizations to see what
the scale of this will be for the
long-term recovery I mean we know from
other disasters we've been responding to
that this is not going to be you know a
matter of weeks or months this is going
to be a multi-year long-term recovery
and this is why uh you know we need a
lot of support and we need people to
give generously because as important as
the short-term needs are now we know
that we're also going to have long-term
needs of people without lifelong
injuries who have significant
psychological issues who may not be able
to return to their livelihood and so we
need to make sure that we're set up to
support people in the long term
thank you Jeremy
um we've now come to the point where we
open up the floor for any questions and
I can see there are several questions in
the Q a box the first one is for Dr
Wessel and the question from Tim
sigsworth from the Press Association is
what is your message for the British
public to donate to the
appealand
with Community cumulative bad conditions
for to uh on the back on the Syrian
people from more to freezing season to
to earthquake to to lack and shortage of
all kinds of the support and and Aid and
the uh the resolution of the security
Council and and difficulties in U.N
agencies to deliver
uh many aspects of the support
to the Syrian people
uh there are high high needs for
securing shelter for for medical aid for
drinking water and some food items and
non-food items and the heating fuel and
electricity and supporting civil defense
in efforts of rescuing the thriving
people under the rubble and and collapse
buildings to to mitigate the impact of
the earthquake
for the Syrian people as there are more
than four thousand uh four thousand
family in Engineers itself
all right
sorry we seem to have lost uh
I hope the question um was responded
there but we'll move on the next
question is uh from Molly blackhall from
the I newspaper uh Molly the question
couple of questions here
it's okay we'll come back to you at the
end sorry
um so the question from Molly from the I
newspaper
um is
but the sorry here we go the lots of
discussion about the first 72 hours
being crucial for saving people trapped
under Rubble as that now has passed is
the focus of the appeal going to be more
on the needs of those affected by the
earthquake such as shelter Healthcare
rather than searching and rescue uh well
Molly as you've seen several of our
members have already been supporting
search and rescue and DC Charities are
on the ground and are drawing down
appeal funds as we speak but sadly
um time is running out as we've said for
pulling people out and there are
millions of people in need of
humanitarian assistance and that's what
the focus of the appeal will be as we
speak among our food water and shelter
the second question is
um around
what is the risk of further aftershocks
and more Quakes and I wonder Salah are
you still with us
we've lost all that
perhaps Jeremy I can see you on this
question what's the risks of further yes
um I'm here can you hear me sorry yes we
can hear you go ahead Salah sorry I lost
some signal where I was
um yeah look um there's still there was
a there was a small after sort of a
Tremor this morning I felt it myself
um it's a very you know it's very scary
when it happens
um and you see the impact that it has
around people there is still that risk
the the the further that days go on the
feeling and the hope is that there is
less risk of the Tremors because of the
time you know just passed from the
initial uh earthquake that took place
[Music]
thank you uh we have a question here
from Ian Eddie
um do you have any idea how many schools
have been destroyed and how children
will be able to continue their education
also how many people have been made
homeless and how will they be housed are
tents the main solution and what's the
more long-term plan perhaps Jeremy if if
I can come to you and Russia if you've
got anything to add on to that that
would be great Jeremy
uh yeah it's a great question and I and
I think you know something to emphasize
is the full scale of this is still
really hard to to get in numbers but
doing the assessments on the ground
we've mobilized our our local volunteers
we're working with you know un
colleagues and other Aid organization
colleagues to try and get an accurate of
just how many schools have been damaged
what the long-term recovery is going to
be
um you know ensuring that full recovery
means schools it means water and
infrastructure it means Healthcare it
means all of the necessary you know
services for for society to function and
you know when we talk about our
long-term recovery that's that's what
we're talking about
at the moment you know exact numbers
we're not sure but we know that for
children especially you know this is a
this is a life-changing event this is an
incredibly traumatic event
wake up in the middle of the night and
then to have you know multiple days of
uh of search and rescue of being in that
you know sleeping in the cold uh so we
want to ensure that you know education
is recover but also you know mental
health uh support for children and
psychosocial recovery for children is
also prioritized in this response
thank you Jeremy Russia anything you
want to add on to this
yeah just agree with Jeremy I think I I
think the picture is still it's still
developing and uh and the immediate
response focused on mainly the basic
needs uh one thing that uh that we are
already also doing and providing is the
mobile psychosocial support services for
uh for for children and I think that is
extremely important at the moment for uh
for for children and uh and I think in
in yeah as we as we progress that there
is a big question about education
education has always missed from uh from
from responses but I think that's a it's
a it's a priority to something to be
discussing later once the full picture
is clearer
thank you Russia and thank you Jeremy
and Dr wassal and Salah uh in in Turkey
we'll now uh draw to a close but before
I do I want to thank all our speakers
especially at this very busy time for
all that you and your teams are doing
responding to the disaster
as we've heard the dec Charities have
been responding since the earthquake
struck Aid is being delivered as we
speak but there is much more to do
the priority right now is to help save
lives through search and rescue and
emergency medical care
sadly hundreds of thousands have lost
their homes and need shelter warmth and
hot food to survive the freezing
conditions
the scale of the damage is hard to
imagine with thousands of buildings
reduced to Rubble this is happening in a
region where millions of people had
already been forced to flee the war in
Syria
donations from the British public will
make a huge difference in enabling DEC
Charities to reach more people we of
course appreciate that this is a
difficult time for all of us but we're
urging everyone to give whatever they
can
the UK government is Aid matching up to
5 million for the dec earthquake appeal
pound for pound so for each pound a
member of the public gives UK government
will match the first 5 million
as we speak DEC Charities are already
drawing down funds to provide that
life-saving assistance
10 pounds could provide blankets for two
people
25 pounds could provide emergency food
for a family for 10 days
and 50 pounds could provide emergency
shelter for two families
thank you for listening